[Music]
let's see if they can find it flashing
the knockout one to faker's gonna be
taking low scout still looking to find
the damage one more thing
and you just don't see a team coming
back from something like that it's just
it's almost unheard of
nearly getting himself killed
and takes him out mouse grabbing the
kill and they're just trying to make
engage so they don't have the damage
it's not a warrior but it's much
squishier
[Applause]
it's time to pull the trigger they do so
they grab the turret now they can move
back to the mountain drake then they can
set up for baron vision the path is
clear for edg
my reaction was my natural reaction as a
fan as a player and as someone whose
mind just got blown all over the wall
behind me from the incredible comeback
that we were seeing right there he's
coming back we're gonna come in here
comes your initiation
[Applause]
we'll find them all
every second counts is presented by
cisco powering the future of esports
at worlds 2017 all eyes were on sk
telecom t1 the defending world champions
had a lot to prove after a narrow
victory the year before and an
uncharacteristic second place finish in
the lck 2017 summer finals it seemed
like cracks were beginning to form in
the skt dynasty fake is going to explode
as the massive damage from prey is going
to say good night to the king of the mid
lane the nexus falls and your new
champions of the lck
and i remember the like this the just
the sentiment right just like the the
feeling in the air was that there was
something
on the horizon and it's like an air of
change
and even even in skt when they were
dominating in spring
it didn't feel like the same level of
domination skt had a pretty difficult
summer despite winning the spring finals
and msi they limped into a disappointing
4th place finish in the summer split
that followed many considered faker to
be the one player the team had holding
them together and going into worlds the
doubts continued it seemed like a safe
bet that skt were going to make it out
of the group but their main opponent was
china's edward gaming edg has denied uzi
once again
edg
they're on to the nexus mako pushing
them back shoving uzi away but here's
today he's trying but he can't do it edg
the most dominant team the region has
ever created will claim their fifth lpl
title edg had just dominated the lpl
summer split and playoffs and were
looking like one of the best teams in
the world and these two teams had some
history while skt was historically
untouchable on the world stage edg was
the only team that ever beat them in an
international best of five
way back at msi 2015. here's the last
engage edg doesn't even see the turrets
eyes on skt
sk telecom t1 are wiped the nexus
turrets are going down lpl's edward
gaming are the 2015
mid-season invitational champions
this is all to say that edg knew how to
beat skt they knew that skt's greatest
weakness was in fact their greatest
player and again we're also looking at
clear up he needs to be active early on
he needs to be successful he wants the
first gank let's see if they can find
him flashing the knockout on the faker
he's going to be taking low skeleton
looking to find the damage one more auto
attack might give it to him
what a start i boy and mako don't seem
to be halting any sort of the aggro that
we've seen earlier arden sensors both up
and running now for these supports as
mid lane they call down the equalizer on
the finger the burst is there who cares
about the shock wave another kill and
they're just trying to make engage where
they don't have the damage it's not a
warrior but it's much squishier than
that will be more not afraid they try to
go back in clear up looking to grab the
lc by the time boy who's got the damage
sensor drops again and clear love takes
him down teams do this to him a lot
you'll see a team's whole plan just be
all right
keep this guy contained sometimes
they're gonna find the pressure they're
gonna find those windows and edg had a
crazy lead throughout the early and mid
game in this game not even 30 minutes
into the game skt were on the ropes edg
collapsed onto faker at every
opportunity setting the greatest player
in the world back in the laning phase
meanwhile edg were ahead by every other
metric too they had a 10 000 gold lead
seven towers to skt's 2 and 2 mountain
drinks skt already lost their mid
inhibitor and super minions pounded
their nexus towers until one of them was
barely left standing and you just don't
see a team coming back from something
like that it's just it's almost unheard
of right and it does happen but
in that particular game that one like
edg like like i said like it was in the
bag 100 in the bag look at the base of
skt it's being absolutely ravaged by
these super minions nexus turret number
one almost already down edg continuing
the pressure here in the bottom lane
scout says i don't care about the
minions i just want to put damage in
this thing skt's options were narrowing
by the second edg had a stranglehold on
the game and they had their pick of how
to win dragon was up baron was almost up
and another wave of super minions could
easily be pushed up to skt's base
basically things looked really bad for
skt at least until edg made one mistake
that was huge for him to actually get a
bigger goal lead
there's saving the drake round he got to
already bang is hiding he's coming bang
looking to come in here comes your
initiation
oh my god your shockwave will find them
all
like all great plays this iconic moment
in league history began long before the
play itself was pulled off edg committed
five members to sieging bot to take the
inner bottom tower but instead of
letting them have it skt chose to fight
overbought as long as possible denying
edg the opportunity to reset and ward
baron pitt that choice set the stage for
the most legendary ambush in league
history edg got the tower but with no
vision on the top side of the map they
could only see skt disappear into the
bushes heading towards barren pit edg
had to assume that skt were doing the
textbook play of setting up vision
around baron pitt in an attempt to hold
off edg or deny baron again let's look
at the wider map here skt were on a
ticking clock if edg took baron the game
was over by pushing the wave mid and
then positioning for baron edg were
effectively putting skt in checkmate
it's time to pull the trigger they do so
they grab the turret now they can move
back to the mountain drake then they can
set up for bare envision the path is
clear for edg
you can understand you can understand
from a2g's perspective that they're like
well i mean but double sums and an
immunity ultimate on our carry what
could go wrong and they also have a 10
000 gold lead right like
absolutely everything says that this
should be completely fine
but uh
no for context while it was a different
patch a team with edg's lead at 15
minutes into the game during the 2017
summer split would have a 90.7
chance of victory according to the
oracle's elixir early game win
probability calculator there had to have
been a conversation about
you know we're about to lose we got to
do a hail mary play if you see me go you
go that's what i figure it was you see
anybody else go
just dump the magazine on them just
follow up throw everything you've got
and get in there edg made all the
tactically correct safe choices
skt had two options
either extend the game and hope for edg
to make a mistake later on or go for a
balls out hail mary play that would cost
them the game if it failed and skt were
not known for that kind of play
unfortunately edg didn't realize that
that's exactly what skt wanted them to
think we're gonna come in here comes
your initiation
oh my god the shock wave will find them
all skt essentially tricked edg into
making the right choice and then
demolished them for it let's break this
down second by second edg walked mid to
push the wave thinking skt went off
toward baron figuring they were safe
they walked just a little too far
they saw faker and backed up but by then
it was too late wolf snuck out of the
brush popped his ult for movement speed
flashed and activated grand entrance for
an absolutely massive four-man knock-up
at the same time huni flashed in with a
feral scream to silence edg's players
this meant that even when they came down
from wolf's grand entrance mako's janna
couldn't turn the team fight with her
ultimate and that's when faker finished
it off with the single most famous
orianna shockwave of all
time is hiding he's coming back looking
to come in here comes your initiation
oh my god the shock wave will find them
all
i think if you don't have
rooney immediately flash silencing
afterwards then there's like remember
there were five flashes on this team
then they immediately flash out you've
just used your gap close to get in and
so you're then standing on an equalizer
and dying like everyone's dead
at that point like
if you mess that up
it has to be that everyone is chain
seaside
and then silenced and then chocolate and
then everyone's there like that's the
only actually just the only way the play
turned around the entire game skt went
from having no hope of winning to near
even contenders and in the end the
eventual winners
skt
legends for a reason find their win skt
are the best team to ever play league of
legends and that man has been there for
all of it i couldn't see a way back the
stats couldn't see a way back but one
team fight initiated by a wolf just like
his famous siren flashing at msi he went
in on rickard the bang was able to clean
it up and from there you see the resign
looks on eg's faces they've had one
stolen from them if everybody's not on
the same page if they aren't able to get
that wombo combo if they don't win that
fight they just lose right like if if
skt actually loses that fight where they
engage on edg like let's say edg just
all manages to
frame perfect flash out of the way i
don't even remember if they had their
flashes up or not but we're just gonna
get hypothetical here and and they all
evade it and they just turn around and
kill them edg wins like like skt has
just done that skt had to get back into
that game right there just look at all
the resources available to edg when wolf
goes in
edg has all 10 summoner spells available
and 4 alts mako died with flash and alt
available if wolf missed all those
abilities would have come to bear on a
defenseless skt edg expected skt to take
the safe route but in a split second skt
decided to take the risk they bet it all
on wolf
why because you don't win games by
playing safe you win games by playing
decisively by making split-second
decisions that turn the tide by looking
at all the options in front of you and
deciding to go out in a blaze of glory
win or lose
sometimes you you want to not lose and
that's never actually the way that
league of legends has ever been won is
by playing not to lose right the slow
bleed out is something that korea has
been notorious for in the past
but it's not if if you're losing you
have to make the play
and
um skt in that particular moment
definitely did as the years have gone on
the play has been recognized as one of
the greatest in league history and many
refer to it as faker's shockwave after
captain flowers's iconic call dang
looking to come in here comes your
initiation
oh my god
we'll find them all
my reaction was my natural reaction as a
fan as a player and as someone whose
mind just got blown all over the wall
behind me from the incredible comeback
that we were seeing right there but
these days many believe that the real
linchpin behind the play working at all
was wolf
i have watched this back a hundred times
to see if i was right or not and to this
day i still believe i was right
everybody has been in a game like this
and everybody that's been down 9 000
gold has seen a five-man jargon
cataclysm has seen a massive recon
engage has seen amumu all four people
right in a big aoe zone and they've all
seen it not mean [ __ ] as soon as faker's
shockwave
turned those health bars
red
and just you saw it wasn't just a nice
cc engage it was everybody just died
that's why faker's shockwave is the call
each member of skt was instrumental
activating their abilities at the
perfect time to swing what should have
been an unwinnable team fight because
like if you don't get that chain to land
perfectly and it's almost like in the
end like faker shockwave was there as a
celebration if you break it down to all
of the nitty-gritty but knowing to hold
like this this play had to have been
planned and coordinated by the whole
team right
and like that level of coordination is
just absolutely beautiful to watch i
love the fact that it still gets brought
up all the time i love the fact that
it's a conversation and a controversy i
even love all the stupid anime avatars
with three followers that see that say
cass was bad caster dumb wolf should
have got credit i love it
because it's that big of a moment skt
went on to fight all the way to the
grand finals they played two close
series in the quarters and semis before
getting destroyed 3-0 by samsung galaxy
the upset is complete as the kills come
through the skt dynasty is over all the
new kings samsung galaxy you're 2017
world champions
at the time everyone considered it to be
the end of an era the end of the skt
dynasty what they didn't realize is that
it actually ended with faker's shockwave
and wolf's grand entrance that
impossible play that incredible
combination of macro strategy perfect
execution and split-second decisive
action
that was skt's magic after that miracle
play their performance was shakier
two 3-2 wins and a 3-0 loss was not the
skt of old no one realized it when they
saw it happen but faker's shockwave was
the last gasp of skt's magic on the
international stage i think what makes
competitive league of legends so
beautiful is the fact that it has to be
all done in tandem
and when five players are on the same
page to that level
that's that's when the magic happens and
that's what makes
that place so good the place still
stands as one of the most incredible
moments in league history and the
players who made it happen remain
legends in their own right because they
made the impossible
possible
this is a game that you will always be
able to use as an example
when somebody brings up yeah it looks
like this one's just about over here x
team has y on the ropes ten thousand
gold leads stuck inside the base you
don't normally see these come back
baker's shockwave is right there in the
back your head though it might be quiet
but it's there
because everybody who saw that play
knows that it's not impossible
[Music]
[Music]
you